[Music]
good morning
and welcome to the spectator health
summit i'm alistair stewart
and i will be your host and uh
interviewing and
interrogating on your behalf as well uh
a remarkable lineup of people and we're
here
right through until uh just about 20
past 12
12 30 perhaps this morning very very
good of you to join us all
shaken by nine months of pandemic with
its tragic deaths and
toll on the health of many including
lockdown
the tier system economic catastrophe
we know may now be on the brink of a
vaccine-led
recovery on the economy there are more
second opinions than i care to
even imagine but we're going to focus
this morning essentially
on the health dimension on the
care issues and also on the life
sciences
and what they've been able to do in this
pandemic
we're going to have a quick look at how
well structured and how
well-funded the nhs was during that
covid19 pandemic phase one how it's
doing now
and what needs to be in place for the
future
with social care the elephant in the
room after a
decade of prevarication and
procrastination
can we should we must we act now to
build a
viable affordable and effective new
model
and what might it look like and after
the heroic efforts of the uk's
universities big pharma and
manufacturers ranging from
high tech to ppe what role can
science and research play in the future
development of other vaccines oxford on
friday coming up with malaria but
there's a lot more
yet to be done on therapies on new
effective bits of
kit and what role can ai artificial
intelligence play
in all of that can we capitalize upon
the growth in the reputation
of the united kingdom in these fields
are are we stuck where we are as always
suffering from a
slight disbelief in our own selves i
hope not
we've got three strong panels we've got
lots of times to take your questions
just
pop them in there and we will deal with
them and we also have a terrific
keynote speaker i'd like to thank our
sponsors msd this morning for
making the event possible and all of the
panels this morning will be available
to watch on replay on spectator tv
website and up on our youtube channel
and you can ask a question to any of our
panelists by
writing in that text box at the bottom
of your screen
or by emailing events spectator
dot co dot uk
right off and running and i'm delighted
to say that the keynote address does
indeed come from
nadeem zahawi nadim was in the business
department and was transferred by the
prime minister
to become officer commanding the entire
vaccine operation
uh and ahead of a very very busy day on
the eve of what could be a monumental
and historic day
tomorrow i'm delighted to say that nadim
has found time to talk to us this
morning
and nadim i'm going to invite you to
make that keynote address and then i'm
going to come back to you
with a couple of questions after that
but first and foremost
over to you sir thank you very much uh
alastair and thank you very much
uh for that introduction uh this is my
first
speaking engagement since uh i took on
the additional
responsibilities as minister for covert
vaccine deployment
uh and it is a fitting occasion to do so
and talk about some of the advances that
we are making in the battle against
the virus uh as one of the oldest weekly
magazines
in the world the spectator has borne
witness
uh to so many threats to public health
since it was first published
i think in 1828 uh it has
seen numerous outbreaks of cholera and
typhus and the so-called
spanish flu which claimed the lives of
millions
and during this uh coronavirus pandemic
i feel grateful that we are
able to call upon something previous
generations
could not uh the power of digital
technologies last year my new colleague
the secretary of state
uh for health and social care matt
hancock came
here and talked about the power of
technology to make
human lives better and this pandemic has
been a
perfect example of what technology can
really
do it's hard to imagine this arduous
year without the technology that has
been keeping
businesses running helping families to
remain connected
and of course allowing our democratic
institutions to perform their vital
role and it is these advances that have
helped our health and care system to
stay
strong even in the greatest public
health emergency in a
generation really allowing um
everything from consultations to keep
going over video
uh linking up you know
many many many uh hundreds of gp
surgeries
with their patients millions of people
to check their symptoms online keeping
them
out of hospitals and of course our nhs
covert 19 app
for contact racing which this year was
the second
the second most downloaded free app uh
for iphones
uh beaten only by zoom uh alastair
a a relentless focus on technology has
proved to be so important during this
pandemic
and we have made the investment so we
could use it
to its full potential and even once we
are through the worst
of this pandemic we will keep working
hard to drive the adoption
of biotech genomics ai and all the
emerging technologies that we know
can make such a huge difference to
people's lives
but this is not the only area where we
are seeing exceptional
growth the global search for a vaccine
has been
uh has really seen phenomenal steps
forward we have uh always known that the
best
long-term solution would be a safe and
effective
vaccine uh after clean water vaccines
are the most effective public health
intervention
ever devised by humanity uh they are
how we eradicated smallpox and how we're
on the brink
of uh eliminating polio and each winter
they help our nhs to stand firm against
obviously the
the flu so in this battle against
coronavirus we've been
working really hard to amass a huge
portfolio of different vaccine
candidates and we have now announced one
of the
biggest portfolios per capita in the
world
last week's news that the mhra and i
paid real tribute to june rain
i've worked very closely with as part of
the vaccines task force
uh had authorized the uh pfizer
bioentech vaccine
really was exceptional news for the
nation uh this means that we have been
able to give it uh the green light after
rigorous clinical uh trials and through
uh
absolute scrutiny from one of the
world's most respected
medical uh regulators i think this is a
real victory not just
for the uk but for humanity and for
all those who believe in the power of
science
but we are not done yet there are still
other vaccine candidates
which are in development including of
course the oxford university astrozenica
vaccine and we still face the monumental
task of deploying
uh as alistair uh introduced me the
vaccine
that are proved uh
that i go through the approval but you
know probably one of the
greatest logistical uh operations that
we have faced
uh as a country uh i'm
really humbled and and proud to have
been asked by the prime minister to
oversee this uh historic rollout in my
role
and from what i have seen so far i'm
confident that we are
in good shape uh the nhs has been
gearing up for this
task for months and the first people
will be getting their jabs
tomorrow tomorrow is going to be i hope
a
v-day and will be remembered as that
as we do this we will obviously
prioritize those who need it most
including the elderly and our brilliant
health and care
staff we owe so much uh
to the pioneers and innovators who have
given us
this incredible hope of a of a better
life beyond the pandemic uh rolling out
a vaccine
uh takes time and so we cannot
uh return to normal life overnight
but it is a i think a pretty major
uh blow to the virus uh showing us all
the path
where we can carefully lift restrictions
over the coming weeks and months and i'm
so proud
of the advances that we have made
today's event
is a really important one uh looking at
our
our shared experiences of our fight
against
this virus and how we can make sure we
are best equipped
for this winter and of course beyond and
i hope
our shared success in developing a
vaccine can provide
optimism and encouragement that we are
making really significant strides in our
effort to defeat
this virus and that we can defeat this
threat to humanity by
really calling upon the ingenuity
possessed by
humanity itself so i hope that you
enjoyed today's event and i'm really
looking forward
to working with you all as i take on
uh this uh what i think is a exciting
but
nevertheless monumental task of
delivering
uh the uh vaccinations for our nation
nadine thank you very much indeed and
thank you for your kind comments about
the spectator magazine
and its noble history there at the very
beginning
um and good of you to find time for us
on on a
really busy day um are you being too
optimistic though
there have been slight hiccups at the
pfizer end of it in the manufacturing
there's even been speculation because of
the brexit talks that
the royal air force may have to put
hercules and other transporters on
standby
to bring the stuff over hey are you
being slightly too optimistic i can
understand why
and be can you tell us definitively when
you think
all of those vulnerable folk will have
had
not the first but also the second job
thank you alistair you're quite right to
uh sort of test the
uh the robustness of of the system
um of course in any manufacturing
process and not least with a
you know a new vaccine there's going to
be some challenges around the
manufacturing process but we've been
working very closely
with pfizer and with the other
candidates vaccine candidates that
hopefully
if the mhra approves we can deploy
as well um i think i want to take it
slowly i've deliberately
um you know said to the team look we've
got to get
this week right and then understand you
know where
are the uh bottlenecks where it where
where is
the the sort of the stress testing the
system
uh this is a massive undertaking uh
initially through hospital hubs and
vaccination centers and then obviously
through uh gps
making sure we get all that right
including
uh how we are going to be able to deploy
a vaccine
that needs to be stored at minus 70
degrees
into our care homes working very closely
with the care home
sector um but it is you're right it's a
balance between
supply on the one hand and then of
course
making sure the supply chains are robust
and then demand on the other side
the bulk of the vaccination will be next
year
um we've got obviously the 800 000
um uh uh shots that have come through
from pfizer bio and tech there is
now a very very robust um
uh delivery uh chain in place
uh we will be able to do as the prime
minister uh hopefully a couple of
million
uh uh before the end of the year and
then the bulk of the deployment
is next year and we'll work through the
categories as
the joint committee for vaccination and
immunization have set out nadim is there
actually a grid that says
care homes by february um over 70s by
march because you
you rightly say yeah we hope to have
most of it done by next year but next
year
includes december as much as it includes
january and july
is there a grid so this is
the biggest challenge is the supply side
so are we working with a single vaccine
are we going to get a second vaccine or
even a third
obviously we've got uh moderna as well
that's now been proved to be effective
um that is
my great challenge is how do i balance
the supply that's coming through
and then making sure that i go through
the categories um
and and essentially deliver uh
as per the um joint committee on
vaccination immunization
you so what i can't tell you now is
exactly what dates and i think that
would be completely foolish and unwise
for any vaccines deployment
manager to do okay
let me button only because of time
and and you're clear on that and
obviously even if there is a grid there
will be fluidity
because if if oxford does go through and
ticks all the boxes then then you'll
have more to play with doing a different
job
uh ditto moderna and so on so hear what
you say
ambitious target but open mind and
flexibility
let me see clarity on a second point you
talked about the possibility of
immunity passports when i've had all of
my jabs and
the rolling stones relaunch their
concerts i can go in and my son can go
and watch southampton football club etc
etc
other ministers pushed back on that the
prime minister himself said we're not
that kind of country
can you this morning rule in or rule out
the notion
of an immunity passport there will not
be an immunity
passport uh i think you know i may have
um misspoken or it was conflated in the
interview i gave
um i was talking about the brilliant use
of the app
uh and then around we have people being
tested you know that we're looking at on
the uh 15th of this month for people
coming into the uk
uh to get a test after after five days
if it's negative then they can
uh come out of quarantine but as far as
vaccinations
we're not looking at an immunity
passport um at all
uh the absolute focus is to make sure we
vaccinate
uh the nine categories that the uh joint
committee
has uh stipulated because actually the
most important thing
ultimately is to um vaccinate the people
who are
at highest risk of death from this
uh virus uh and if we can do that
uh the the sooner we do that the sooner
we can get back to
normal life all right two final
questions one you talked
in your keynote address about the power
of technology
and you gave track and trace uh the app
as an example of it
you're a former business minister as
well as now working with matt hancock
on the health side and the vaccine side
has this
government learned the key lesson
of not doing deals with mates
in delivery of important bits of kit who
may not have the best track record
and not always nadine going to the nhs
and their boffins
to come up with ideas has the government
learn that you need to go to the very
best people whomsoever they are
to get crucial jobs done
look great question so i was deeply
engaged
and involved in the ventilator challenge
where we brought together
was a call to arms by the prime minister
to bring the best of british engineering
and ingenuity and innovation together
and we we did that you know
we had everybody from airbus to ford to
a small company called pendleton in
oxfordshire
come together and deliver that uh i
think
you know if you're referring to the uh
acquisition of ppe
where we bought something like uh uh you
know
30 billion pieces or whatever it was of
ppe
remember march was a time when the whole
world was trying to source ppe
the united kingdom could only produce
one percent
one percent of its ppe needs them uh
all the uh the contracts go through a
rigorous process they will all be
published in time people will be able to
see them on gov dot uk
and so yes of course we'll learn from
our mistakes if that's your question
of course we'll learn from our mistake
but all i'm saying is we need to put in
perspective today
december 2020 we can produce the uk can
produce 70 percent
7-0 of his ppe needs versus 1
in march final question and a quick one
we will be having a panel later on about
the
the role of the uk life sciences base
uh which government has has committed to
over the years and
you've been directly involved in it um
do you believe that the commitment is
in its early nascent stages or has
what oxford university
with astrazeneca done together in
collaboration
indicate a brand new model for uk life
sciences
government university and and capitalism
if you like
functioning in sweet harmony um
so i co-chair the office for life
science and what uh sir john bell has
done
is remarkable um it's been you know many
many years of working together we're on
our third iteration
of what we call a sector deal where we
work with the sector to be really
ambitious of what we can do
in the uk it is no it is no surprise
that we've had oxford and other
incredible
scientists working on the vaccine in the
united kingdom
there is real opportunity on um
clinical trials which we're working
because we have this
extraordinary ability with an integrated
system that is called the nhs
to be able to do the most efficient uh
uh
trials in the world and and that has
been demonstrated we've got one of the
best regulators
in the world in mhra and that's proven
uh now
it's worth during this uh pandemic which
obviously
you know large pharmaceutical companies
look at think wow that's incredible we
really should be when they're making
investment decisions on these things
and of course there are opportunities
around diagnostics
so testing uh vaccine manufacturing
uh we we're brilliant at um
you know the catapults that we've set up
and the cell and gene therapy
um i want us to get you know as good
as we are in the r the research that
as we are in the d if we're really good
in the development i.e
growing these um this innovation out of
our universities
into real businesses then we would have
made a huge difference
what a fascinating point to end on
nadeem zahawi
uh the r we're very good at d we're
getting better at but there's an m as
well
manufacturing let's make sure we can do
an awful lot of that here in the uk as
well
i know you're a busy man uh particularly
now and
uh on behalf of all of us good luck
tomorrow um and
uh and thank you for finding time uh for
us this morning nadim's are we there the
uh minister for vaccines um
uh talking about the power of technology
talking about having learnt lessons
uh uh on expenditure and and cooperation
uh with the with the private sector uh
and on employment
and uh reminding us to remember that
there are other vaccine candidates
still coming through and there is a grid
for delivery
but it is fluid nadine thank you very
much indeed
[Music]
you